Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and, no, I am not lying when I say that.
This baby faced gentleman that you see in front of you, is indeed, the real Markiplier.
And, uh, when I'm unbearded, and I've already got a little stubble growing,
But when I'm unbearded, I suddenly drop back to who I was in the year 2012.
And I did this on the charity live stream that we just did this weekend.
And, uh, it was, it was really fun.
I mean, uh, excuse also the makeup and the gold in my hair,
don't mind any of that.
That's coming out for a video, uh, later this week.
But I just wanted to take the time to say hi to you guys again.
And...
...I don't know, I thought it was a good opportunity to kinda reintroduce myself.
Because, honestly, I haven't done that in a while and
some of you may wonder why I would need to reintroduce myself.
But I've always felt that it was important to do that
because it's very easy to become a caricature of yourself.
And what I mean by that, it's very easy for people to
assume that they know who you are unless you keep up with that idea.
And the idea of who you are is sometimes a very hard concept to lockdown.
But I'll start with the basics.
Hi, my name is Mark.
My middle name is Edward.
My last name is Fishbach.
I was born on Oahu, Hawaii in Honolulu
on a military base, um, to my dad and mom.
Like oddly enough, that is a similar story for me as well.
I was not graced upon this Earth by the gods.
As some people have, uh, suspected but
Um, I'm a formal biomedical engineering student.
I've been doing Youtube for over five years now.
And it's been an incredible ride thus far.
And what really brought this about is not only did I go baby face and I, I look exactly like I did back in those days.
But also we watched, um, one of my old vlogs back on stream.
It was for my, uh, my birthday.
Oddly enough, I just turned 23, I think.
And, um...
Like on that stream, I said some really silly-sounding things at the time.
Er, now they do, looking back.
I was talking about the statistics of the channel.
And I was talking about how I decided that I wanted to be a BIG youtuber someday.
When I grew up, I was gonna be a big youtuber.
And, uh...
It, it was really interesting to see because at the age of 23
Like
I had already, like grown up.
I had already grown up at that point.
Or at least, I thought I did.
Until I got to that point.
Like I had worked an office job.
I wore a tie to work everyday.
And I sat in the cubicle doing engineering work.
And I thought that was gonna be my life.
And I was, I was okay with that at the time, and then I found something else
that lead me into doing Youtube.
And I can talk about that or you can watch some videos that I've made in the past that talk about that.
But long story short,
I had a medical problem.
I had a tumor.
I got that removed and that lead me to
trying to make videos for a living.
And it worked, it really did.
And...
Five years later, I have had more success than I could ever hope for.
And, in the journey,
We've managed to build one of the greatest communities I've ever seen.
Anywhere.
And I am so incredibly proud of what you guys have done and I'm so incredibly--
Incre-incredibly proud of you guys joining us for these streams every single weekend
And I'm so incredibly proud of you guys continuing to champion the causes that we talk about.
Because, it's not just about the fact that we're able to raise more money than ever before.
And, and I don't know the final count from this weekend,
But I'll let you guys know as soon as I find that out.
But it's not just about that. It's not just about us having these live streams every month
And that's the end of it.
It's the fact that it echos beyond what we do on that day.
Like the, the resounding success of those live streams come,
Yes, from the donations being made in the tangible good that you see out of that,
But also,
From how it affects other people that want to do those things.
The ripple that it has.
And I'm not just saying, like,
I'm not taking credit for any of this because
I've always said it that it's you guys that manage to do it.
And it's the community that rallies around what we do.
But, it's so amazing to see it ripple and continue and inspire
generations to come.
To do this amazing things and to raise money for charity and go out there and try to change the world.
And coming from the perspective of reintroducing you--myself to you guys is the idea of what I want to be when I *laughs* grow up.
And that sounds like a silly thing to say, but it's true, like
What do I want to be when I grow up?
'Cause I've been doing this for five years.
I'm 27 years old, which is old by some standards.
But if you ask anyone older than me, I am still incredibly young.
[Goofy] And it looks it right now with my baby face,
But I'm still incredibly young and I have so many other ambitions for what I want to do.
And it all revolves around this incredible community that we have here.
And I am so...
So excited, like everyday, I'm excited for the future.
Everyday, I'm excited for what's to come.
Everyday, I'm excited to, to, to make new challenges for myself and exceed them.
Or not meet them or fail and try again.
But never stop creating.
You know, in the endeavor.
And that's one of the most beautiful things that I can see coming out of the community is creation.
Like you guys going out and making things and starting your own channels and starting your own art projects.
And finding new ways to blaze your trail and go out there.
And, and, and, and I see that as just a little piece of what I did in the beginning of all this craziness.
And I'm really happy.
I don't know, I'm just really happy to be here.
And, and admittedly, things have been crazy on my end because
We've been moving offices because like we said on the stream.
In case you missed it,
the last of it that we had, it was very nice-looking,
but it was horrifying.
Like every single area in that office was horror.
Like there was a bug wall where bugs would just start crawling out of the walls at random.
You never know when a centipede was about to start coming out of there.
There was a wall that, not only flooded, but any computer equipment that you would ever put in that corner,
would die, inevitably.
We went through three different computers.
We resurrected a computer twice.
And put it back in the same computer corner and it just blew up.
Each and every time. It just blew up.
We have no idea why, so it's been crazy trying to move offices to, uh, this new one that we're gonna get it set up for the next stream.
Real nice and you're gonna see that, but...
Just, thank you, guys...
Thank you guys for holding onto the hope that...
...we can make the world a better place.
And if I had to summarize what I wanna be when I "grow up", it would be...
I wanna change the world.
I don't just wanna make a small impact on the world.
And I can't do that alone, I never could.
I never would be able to do that alone.
But now, in this community, I have an opportunity.
And I have a responsibility to guide you guys, and hopefully
point you guys in the right direction. And even if it comes down to the point where I am not the one who's guiding you
and it's you who's guiding me...
Then that's what it comes to. But either way, I wanna change the world.
I wanna make a lasting impact on it.
Hopefully, for the better by the way.
This is all for the better, not saying change the world for the worst.
But change the world for the better, and make a difference.
Today, and tomorrow, and we talked about doing this on the stream.
We had this idea that we'll make changes that ripple beyond our own lives.
That when our times comes and goes...
...we'll know...
...that the generations that follow us will follow in our footsteps and be able to lead themselves down a path to a brighter future.
And that is a beautiful idea.
And that's what I want.
In this silly videos that I make, and I make silly videos...
...comes something more profound and more amazing than I could've ever hoped for.
So, just thank you everybody so much for watching.
I don't think I'm gonna keep the baby face
I, I, I do like the beard.
We did it for a very specific reason that you're gonna see very soon, probably this Friday, I believe.
But it's really, really, really cool to be in the middle of the most amazing time in my life.
And I believe I'm in the middle of it.
Because it's.. it's astonishing.
It really is, the things that I can do now.
And the things that we can do together.
And I'm grateful for that every single day.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always, I will see you...
...in the next video.
Buh-bye!
Bye, bye-bye...